مساء الخير اذا كان فيه حد ما حضرتكم لم
يسمع عن الصاروخ الروسي اسره ومائه عليه
ان يتابع اخباره من الان اللي هي جمله
الصحف ووسائل الاعلام والقنوات
التلفزيونيه اذا كان حريصا على ان يفهم
خريطه التحالفات الجديده في المنطقه هو
الشريف اصر به ما هو صاروخ بيمثل ايقونه
الدفاع الجو الروسي وعنده مزايا كثيره من
بينها قدرته على التعامل مع تمارين هدف
معادي في نفس الوقت و يمثل خطرا كبيرا على
المقاتلات المعاديه
المشكله المشكله ان الاتراك في 2017 قرروا
التفاوض لشراء هذه المنظومه بل وتعاقدوا
عليها الامر اللي اصاب الامريكان وحلفاء
الاتراك الغربيين في حلف شمال الاطلسي
بالصدمه في البدايه اعتقدوا ان الرئيس
التركي بيون ويستخدم الصاروخ كنوع من ال
من وفر او المناوره
للحصول على الامتيازات او تنازلات من
حلفائه في ملفات اخرى لكن
بان الرجل الجاد في شراء منظومه الصواريخ
طيب اه المشكله في انه الرئيس بوش الرئيس
التركي اشترى الصواريخ الهند اشترت
المنظومه الصين اشترت المنظومه عشرات من
دول العالم مهتمه بمعرفه مزايا وعيوب
المنظومه للتعاقد على شرائها المشكله انه
تركيا دوله اساسيه في حلف شمال الاطلسي
وما هو حلف الشمال الاطلسي او حلف النيتو
والحلف الان شي بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
بهدف واحد رئيس و هو حمايه المعسكر الغربي
او الدول الغربيه من اخطار الاتحاد
السوفياتي اولا ثم لاحقا الان بعد زوال
الاتحاد السوفياتي اخطار اللي بتمثل ها
الدوله الروسيه فلا يعقل انه دوله في حلف
شمال الاطلسي تتعاقد على شراء منظومه
الدفاع الجوي هي في الاساس عمولات علشان
تهدد المقاتلات الامريكيه والغربيه
الامريكان حول يقنعوا الرئيس التركي
بالعدول عن الصفقه الاول استخدموا مع
الاجراءات وسالوه ماذا تريد يعني ايه
الهدف اللي انت عاوزه من التعاقد على
الصفقه فالون بديه اللي انا عاوز اننا
وامن دفاعات
القويه بشكل جيد واحمي حدودي وامني يعني
اعرضوا عليه مجموعه من المنظومات ال
متشابهه من انتاج الدول الغربيه لكن
العسكريين الوفود العسكريه التي يفرضها
رئيس التركي لم تبدي اهتماما كبيرا فعرضوا
عليه منظومه تريد اللي هو ما كانوا
بيتركوا في امداد الاطراد بها
اعجبته منظومه تقولون جيد ان اشتري صواريخ
باتريوت لكن ايضا سوف اشتري الصوماليه
الامر اللي اذا للامريكان طب ما احنا
بتقدم تريد كبديل عن ما حاجتك الى اسره من
بداوا مع اصرار الرئيس التركي انه مارسه
عليه نوع من الدخول ببساطه مع تعدد اشكال
ها هو حرمانه من الحصول على الاسلحه
الغربيه اللي هي قوات
الامن القومي التركي
الغالبيه العظمى كل الاسلحه التركيه هي
استحي في الحقيقه غربيها وبدا بالتهديد
بحرمانه من المقاتله اف 35
كما هي المقاتله اف 35
السلاح الجوي الامريكي التي تعتزم
الولايات المتحده انها تكون المقاتله
الرئيسه بعد ان 16 واف 15 ما هي المقاتله
الرئيسه للقوات الجويه الامريكيه للدول
الحليفه في حلف شمال الاطلسي وبالتالي
وكمان هو الرئيس
التركي او الدوله التركيه الجيش التركي
كان بيخطط انه يعمل عمليه 5 16 اللي هي
المقاتله الرئيسيه الجيش التركي على سنه
الفين وثلاثه وعشرين على ان يحل معك انها
المقاتله اف 35 اللي بيسموها الطائره
الشرح اولا ستين
وتعاقد بالفعل على شرائه مقاتله منها مش
بس تعاقد هذا هو الجيش او الدوله التركيه
بتشارك في تمويل
الالاف خمسه وثلاثين تصنيعها لان المعمول
بها في حلف الشمال الاطلسي ان المصنع
الرئيس الولايات المتحده لكن الدول
المستفيده الدول الاساسيه في حلف شمال
الاطلسي بتسهل في عمليه التمويل يعني
عمليه تمويل التصنيع بالاضافه انه احيانا
بتشارك بتصنيع اجزاء من المقاتله اجزاء
مؤثره او الى انه التكنولوجيا الساعه عند
الولايات المتحده لكن بردو بعد التهديد
بحرمانه من
الخمسه والثلاثين اللي او ال مقاتلتين
منهم بيت ضرب عليها الاتراك الان مقاتلين
اتراك طيارين اتراك في احد القواعد
العسكريه الامريكيه
والمفروض تيجي اول اثنين منهم في نهايه
العام الحالي 2019 التهديد لم يرجع رئيس
التركي اللي اصر على انه هو مواطن في كل
الاحوال الشراء السبعمائه
الامريكان وحلفاؤه بالاوروبيين عندهم يعني
مصدرين اساسيين
المخاوف من الاسر المصدر الاولاني هو سبب
تقني وفني عسكري انه هم عندهم قناعه ان
والاسلاميه المتطور قادر على ان يحصل على
الد او الاسرار المقابله في خمسه وثلاثين
لانه الوضع في حال شراء الاتراك لاسره
اللي هو معمول بيستهدف الاسلحه الغربيه
بالدرجه الاولى هي بوضع غريب شويه بالنسبه
للامريكان الكثير من الشيوعيه انه الدوله
الحليفه التركيه اللي هي
الدوله في حلف الشمال الاطلسي المتعاقده
على المقاتلات الامريكيه في ال السماء
ومتعاقده على منظومه الصواريخ ارض جو اللي
بتستهدف هذه المقاتله في الارض وان هذه
المنظومه قادره على ان تحصل على كل
الاسرار والتكنولوجيا الامريكيه في افق 35
وتقع في يد العسكريين الروس يقولون ان
تثير هذه المنظومه معنا كاننا وضعنا خمسه
وثلاثين في احد المطارات الروسيه وتركناها
للروس طبعا الرئيس الروسي حاول الرئيس
التركي حاول عبثا انه يقول لهم ان هذا
الكلام غير سليم وانه لن يسمح له في تركيب
المنظومه ولا بادارتها ولا بانه ممكن
يضعوا فيها اي وسيله للتجسس على طائرات اف
الامريكان لم يقتنعوا بذلك وجزء من عدم
قناعتهم هو ادراكهم او هكذا يقولون انه
الاتراك ليس لديهم الخبرات كبيره في مجال
في مجال في هذا النوع من الصواريخ
وبالتالي في الغالب سوف يستعين العسكريين
السبب الثاني
مخاوف الامريكان
اقتصاديا
صناعه السلاح مربحه جدا في العالم
ومتوسط المبيعات سنويا حوالي مائه مليار
دولار سنويا
تلتها يستحوذ عليها الامريكان والباقي
المقسم على دول العالم في المركز الثاني
الروس ثم ياتي عدد من الدول عاده
الفرنسيين الالمان ثم ياتي دول اخرى دول
اخرى تقدمت مؤخرا في ال يعني في الترتيب
الصين اللي احتلت المركز الخامس مزحه
الدول مهمه زي بريطانيا وفي توقعات من
مراكز الابحاث متخصصه انها تقف للمركز
الثالث قريبا بعد الولايات المتحده
والروس هذا معناه انه لو الاطراف اشتروا
هذه المنظومه هذا سوف يعرض دول كثيره تشكل
السلاح الروس لانه اذا كان الدوله في حلف
الشمال الاطلسي
تشتري السلاح الروسي او تفضله على سلام
غربيه ذا ممكن يعطي جاذبيه اكبر للسلاح
الروسي خصوصا مع انه مع تصاعد او مع زياده
الاهتمام الدول من الدول اللي هي في
المعسكر الغربي زي العراق اللي بقت واحده
من اكثر دول العالم شرعي السلاح الروسي
السعوديه نفسها بعد عندها اهتمام ب منظومه
السلاح الروسيه ال ال ودول اخرى قادمه
يعني وبالتالي المساله التي تعنى خساره
الى مبيعات الاسلحه للشركات الامريكيه
والغربيه من ناحيه اخرى الاتراك عندهم
دوافع كثيره للاتجاه الى السلاح الروسي
علشان نفهم نفهم اطار شويه الاحباط التركي
من الغرب احباط متعدد المستويات في اللي
على مستوى الاتحاد الاوروبي بعد حوالي
سبعين سنه واكثر من سبعين سنه من التفاوض
للدخول كعضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي يدرك انه
لن يدخل ولا نيت اثنين على مستوى التسليح
الدوله التركيه كثيره الشكوى منذ ان بدات
طموح في السبعينات والثمانينات لبناء
صناعه الدفاع او صناعه السلاح محليه خاصه
بها بتشكر ان الامريكان دائما
في مساله توطين
التكنولوجيا من السلاح الذي يشترونه من
الولايات المتحده يعني مع كل سلاح الاتراك
زي دول اخرى بتشتري ب تشترط توطين
التكنولوجيا والامريكان بطبقه كان عندهم
اه يعني اعتبارهم اعتبر ان هي حريصه للدول
الحليفه تبقى الدول القضيه لانها تستفيد
من قوتها لكن في نفس الوقت تتضرر من فكر
التوطين التكنولوجيا العسكريه لان هذا
يحرمها مستقبلا من مبيعات هي احد مصادر
دخلها المهمه
الامريكان ال الاتراك ايضا بشكل اكبر في
السنوات الاخيره من الاختلاف والتباين
الكبير جدا في السياسات والمصالح بين
البلدين خصوصا في الملف سوري شديد جدا
اصبح الامريكان والاطراف الهمه
حلفاء منذ هذا الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وتشارك في الحرب على الاتحاد السوفياتي
السابق يقف في معسكرين متدين على الساحه
السوريه الامريكان بيدعمه الاكراد سياسيا
وعسكريا واقتصاديا فيما الاكراد بوجهه
والضرب الاكراد
فاصبحوا فيه خلاف كبير في القسم والخلاف
وصل الى حد ان الرئيس التركي الرئيس
الامريكي اسف حد التركيه يعني هي فكرت في
توجيه ضربه الى الاتراك اللي بيمثله خطر
محدقه على الاتراك سوف سوف يقوم الرئيس
الامريكي ب اه
يعني يدمر الاقتصاد الامن التركي وبالتالي
مصدر احباط اخر من مصادر الاحباط المهمه
والمسكوت عنها ولا الرئيس التركي لا يتحدث
عنها علنا ولكنها معروفه هو قناعه انه
الانقلاب اللي تم محاوله الانقلاب اللي تم
في يوليو 2016
يعتقد انها محاوله دبرها الامريكان
وحلفائهم اذا كانوا من دول اوروبيه او
الدول العربيه زي الامارات هكذا يعتقد
وبالتالي هو عند قناعه ان هذه الدول شاركت
في محاوله التخلص منه ولذلك فهو راغب في
الاستقلال تدريجيا عن المعسكر الغربي
اقتصاديا وسياسيا وعسكريا
واثر بعمليه
نتيجه هذا التحول الكبير
انه البعض بيقول انه الرئيس التركي معاوز
الاسر والعمليه مش بس علشان يحفظ فيها امن
والخارجي ولكن تخوفه من احتمال تعرض
لمحاوله ان كلام اخرى بيحاول يحقق منها
بانه يصطفي مجموعه من الضباط اللي يثق فيه
ولائهم يقوم بتدريبهم على هذه المنطقه
علشان تحميه من الاخطار الخارجيه وتستخدم
ضد اي محاوله من
الطيارين الاتراك مستقبلا ان نفكر بعضهم
في الانقلاب على الرئيس التركي الحقيقه
انه قدمنا الان ال ال قضيه شائكه
قدمنا اكثر من سيناريو اذا السيناريو
المتفائل بالنسبه للبلدين انه يصلوا الى
حل وسط بمعنى مثلا انه ينجح الرئيس التركي
بان الرئيس التركي يتراجع عن الصفقه وفي
الحاله دي يغضب الروس لكن سوف تظل تركيا
حليف رئيسي للولايات المتحده
وبعدين اه يعني تجاوز خلافاتهم اللي حصلت
مرات عديده على مدار السنوات الكثيره
الماضيه تنفيها وتجاوز واحد خصوصا بعد سنه
اربعه وسبعين
والغزو التركي لقبرص طيب او انه يتمسك كل
طرف من الطرفين
بموقفه في الحاله ده يكون معناها طلاق
فعلى اطلاق عمليه ما بين تركيا و حلف
الشمال الاطلسي بده يغير كثير من خريطه
التحالفات في المنطقه
الحقيقه انه خريطه التحالفات بدات تتغير
بالفعل
وتركيا اللي بتحاول تبع التدريجيه انا عن
الغرب مش بس تكتفي بالتعاقد على سلاح روسي
بتحاول تعمل خلف خاص ب اه هي بعيده تماما
عن الحي في الغربيه وبعيدا عن سياسات
الولايات المتحده بشكل هو اقدامها التحالف
بيضم مين
وعاوز اعمل ايه لا يستحق منها حلقه ثانيه
ان شاء الله اشكركم والى لقاء اخر
نعم